how would you describe in Broad terms or
tattoos ghetto ghetto fabulous what's up
this your favorite Hood hottest princess
sexy mother red and these is my
tattoos my first tattoo was this loyalty
on my chest I was 16 when I got this cuz
I had a boyfriend that was in jail and I
was being loyal to him so I'm like I'm
going get loyalty I was just doing some
I just be getting sh after my mom
was like when I turned 16 I get tattoos
and stuff I just start going crazy just
getting all kind of but I tricked her
and was like I'mma get your name that's
how y your mom let you get a tattoo I'm
I'mma get your name then I came back I
had this I got her name on me right here
Andrea big Dre my last tattoo I got I
think it was this one the sexy yeah it
was the sexy it was just sexy so I'm
like let me get let me get it on my face
my son name Chucky the sexy oh and the
St Louis where I'm from yeah but I don't
think I'm going to do no more everybody
keep saying I don't don't put no more
tattoos on your face I got sexy right on
my butt I got sexy on my face I got sexy
somewhere else too I don't know it's
somewhere on
me I like bbee so I got a bie tattoo I
got this when I was in high school too I
just feel like I'm a getto barie it got
my favorite color pink in there it's
just cute to me this my favorite tattoo
for real like this really my favorite
tattoo sometimes I forget that it even
say Barbie and then they'll notice like
oh you straight got Barbie on you oh no
that's my favorite tattoo on the back of
my legs the sexy devil cuz I'm the sexy
devil so I'm like I just want to get my
thighs cuz I ain't have no tattoos on
the back of my body for real so I just
got that and then I got this little bad
girl sign tattoo with the heart and a
Halo and a devil tail on it I got this
because I got like eczema where I used
to have it real bad and it left like
little marks on my skin so I just went
it got all the little marks covered up
I'm like the man freestyled them too he
like I'm just cover all the little marks
I'm a young hot so I'm like let me
get some flames on my leg oh I forgot I
even had a heart right there I'm
thinking I just had two roses I went and
got something added right here too I'm
like I wanted to fill my neck in it was
empty right there so I'm like I want to
fill it up so I just got a heart and
then I got a little flower I just be
doing it kind of hurt it cuz it's
on the front of your neck like where you
breathe it but I really take all my
tattoos like I don't know it's
therapeutic sometimes mhm butts hurt
butt tattoos hurt it hurt it the big
butterfly tattoo hurt it like it was
making me squeeze my booty cheeks in I
was just getting like some of these
tattoos don't even mean nothing I just
be like I want to put something right
here and then I just think of something
to put right there yeah some of the
stuff I got on there twice like the
butterflies I got this on I got like
three sets of butterflies on me two sets
of roses cuz I got the no actually I got
three sets of Rose oh yep this this and
then on my
neck me and my best friend we got
matching bows on our chest and then all
my sisters and my close friends they got
this same stamp but they get it like
somewhere on their body like different
places that's my step daddy he got
killed when I was younger so I just went
and got that oh the breast cancer sign
yeah that's from my granny my granny had
passed from breast cancer and I was
young when I got this cuz I wouldn't
have got it that little on my arm I
would have got something bigger like to
represent her I got this matching with
my friend cuz we like soulmates soul
ties we got a weird pinkies and our
pinkies look alike so we both went and
got like the same tattoo by our Pinky
and we put them together like this like
when we see each other I got boss on my
hands with some dollar signs and then I
got a heart my letter initial a cursive
j a diamond and then another dollar sign
I just be putting dollar signs all on me
and then I got some diamonds going on my
belly these diamonds go on my leg all
the way up to my
stomach I got some butterflies going on
my back I got the word Savage at the
bottom like a stamp I'm like I'm a
Savage let me get Savage on my back me
and my friends we be going together like
me and my best friend we went to get a
lot of tattoos together like she'll get
her own stuff but it don't got to even
be matching we'll just be like let's go
get Tedy like and I'll call her we just
go meet each other up there just to do
something together we got a lot of
tattoos together and then this butterfly
on my knee I just got that just to fill
in something I got my baby daddy name on
my ankle I'll just lose count cuz I
forget some of the ones I got and I be
like dang I forgot to count them it's
over like 30 something though cuz I sat
there and counted I tried to start from
the bottom just like then I lose count
for getting like oh I got one back there
too oh I got something I'm probably
going to be getting stuff when I'm old
cuz I like whatever I want to do I just
do it probably going to be thinking of
some like might want to get my
grandkids name Ted so I just go do some
like
that for real would you ever get a cute
tattoo really would you get a sexy red
tat you yeah
right